we live in a society that much is true
in the SCP foundation's native universe
or any others but whenever you live in a
society there is always the threat that
someone with malicious intent will come
and tear your carefully constructed
Society down people like say the Joker
the iconic terrifying and Darkly
hilarious clown Prince of Crime from the
world of DC Comics The Joker has been
causing chaos from the worlds of comics
cartoons movies TV shows and video games
for almost a century from Romero to
Nicholson to Hamel to ledger to Phoenix
and when he's not duking it out with the
Dark Knight he's doing everything he can
to prove that the world is only one bad
day away from Total pandemonium and to
that end he regularly allies with
anomalous entities people and groups
that's more than enough to put him in
the sights of the SCP Foundation So
today we're using the trusty anometron
6000 our our state-of-the-art simulation
computer made through proprietary
anomalous means to see how exactly a
tussle with the joker might go and if
there's one thing we know about this
grease painted gangster it's that
regardless of where he pops up he always
needs a mentally ill dude with an
incredibly tragic backstory and a bunch
of special skills and gadgets to take
him down enter the SCP foundation's very
own Dr Jack Bright it's an Unstoppable
chaotic Force versus an immovable
chaotic object but who will win let's
crank up the machine and find out it was
pandemonium over at site 19 bodies
littered the ground the walls were
perforated with bullet holes several
anomalies had been stolen and another
several had escaped it was one of those
worst case scenario type situations and
naturally this meant a guaranteed
stressful morning for the unemittable
psych director Dr bright who already had
enough on his plate trying to organize
the annual SCP Foundation Christmas
party he entered the main hall where a
heated confrontation between Foundation
agents and a group of heavily armed
inner lopers had taken place jack was
flanked on both sides by several mobile
task force operatives who had been
dispatched to help fight off these foes
but by the time they'd arrived The
Intruders had already disappeared Dr
Brian shook his head and tutted
surveying the room there were at least
20 or 30 bodies considerable property
damage and even green graffiti
spray-painted on the walls depicting
mostly crude symbols like evil smiley
faces Anarchy A's the Stussy s and some
words we need to blur out because SCP
explained is a family show in some
regards it had all the Hallmarks of a
typical chaos Insurgency raid a group of
heavily armed operatives steaming in
guns blazing indulging in a little Smash
and grab and leaving a trailer
Foundation operative Blood on the way
out but there were certain details here
that gave Dr bright pause before
resetting the typical X days since chaos
Insurgency attack on the break room
whiteboard
Dr bright waded forward into the Carnage
stepping delicately around multiple
bodies on the ground there were many of
those strange little wind-up chattering
teeth producing tinny laughter from
their tiny voice boxes there was a funny
smell lingering in the air almost like
circus peanuts and cotton candy but the
weirdest thing of all was what happened
to the bodies of foundation operatives
themselves all had pale faces wide
staring eyes and bright red grins why
had so many of them died bearing such
grotesque Smiles was this some new
anomalous entity or weapon that bright
had never even heard of when the chaos
Insurgency discovered an anomaly before
the foundation it never boated well for
anyone that's when Dr bright heard
something from one of the bodies on the
ground a deep hacking cough Dr bright
immediately ran over to the body in
question it was a junior researcher
who'd had the presence of mind to put on
a gas mask and play possum as soon as
the attack began leaving him the only
Survivor and eyewitness to the account
as The Interlopers had been smart enough
to kill all the cameras before the
attack began
thanked 343 somebody survived the
catastrophe Dr bright said wiping some
sweat from his brow what the heck
happened here kid the junior researcher
slid off his gas mask revealing his
trembling tear streak face it took him a
moment of steadying himself to speak
I I've never seen anything like this it
was a chaos Insurgency raid I I
recognize all the uniforms from those
seminars we needed to take an
orientation but there was this one guy
with them I never seen anything like him
what uh what kind of guy are we talking
about here bright asked he he had a
white face like a clown with these big
red lips and green hair and he wore a
purple suit and that laugh God I'm never
gonna forget that laugh when he came in
he released some kind of toxin I saw
everyone who got enveloped by the cloud
start laughing like him not happy
laughing laughing like it hurt but they
couldn't stop I was able to put on my
gas mask just in time but then the chaos
Insurgency guys with him opened fire it
was 10 minutes of hell and then they
were just all gone and with that the
junior researcher passed out from the
stress of recalling his traumatic
incident bright ordered some of his
subordinates to cart the kid off to the
medical ward while they straightened the
rest of this madness out so the chaos
Insurgency had found themselves a new
star operative or some new Maniac is out
there calling the shots now either way
Bad News Bears Dr Wright narrowed his
eyes pensively and said I think a man
who calls himself The Joker was behind
this attack what makes you think this
doctor asked Sergeant Richards an MTF
officer the graffiti is definitely a
pretty strong clue bright replied on the
wall to the left of right and Richards
were the words I was behind this side
The Joker P.S
[Laughter]
etched out in the same garish green
spray paint as with any attack on the
SCP foundation's primary base Dr bright
needed to perform a debrief with 05-1
the leader of the o5 council had
discussed the plans for how they want to
deal with this new Joker fellow that
seems to be buddy buddy with the chaos
Insurgency now Dr bright sat at the end
of a frankly unnecessary long meeting
table with a live video feed to 05-1's
undisclosed secure location on the other
end but things were about to get a whole
lot worse because because as Dr bright
explained the situation 205-1 the last
thing he expected in response was for
the man to say oh God him again as it
turned out in the anxiety-inducing Spiel
that Dr bright would receive from 05-1
this Joker had really been making a name
for himself in the SCP foundation's bad
books he'd done several jobs with the
chaos Insurgency but that was apparently
only the start of his work with the
foundation's various most misaligned
groups of Interest Foundation informants
have reported that the Joker the moniker
they'd need to stick with since
seemingly Nobody Knows the guy's true
name had sold several of the high-value
anomalies he'd collected with the chaos
Insurgency to the heartless money men at
Marshall Carter and dark limited and
he'd been using the resulting Capital to
fund himself in increasingly large and
dangerous criminal Empire but it didn't
stop there given the Joker's silly yet
deadly clown theme he'd been using his
ill-gotten gains to purchase Whimsical
Weaponry from the wondertainment
corporation and to give him plenty of
anomalous Manpower he'd been headhunting
the various super-powered freaks working
at Hermann Fuller's circus of the
disquieting whom he lured over with both
higher pay and comprehensive company
dental insurance to make sure those big
evil smiles were full of pearly whites
nobody knew what his end goal was but it
was clear that the Joker was now an
established Power Player amongst the
Deluge of dangerous groups of Interest
out there at the expense of many many
Foundation lives
so what are we gonna do about him Dr
bright asked send over the boys from red
right hand to give him the uh JFK
special don't you think we've already
tried that approach Jack please don't
insult my intelligence with such an
obvious suggestion 05-1 replied we've
sent numerous hit squads to take him out
but he always seems to be one step ahead
the last one got a tip off that he'd be
hiding in a penthouse apartment in
Gotham City some absolute toilet bowl of
a town but when the team arrived all
they saw was a comically large gift wrap
present with a little note saying follow
the SCP Foundation lots of love Mr J
well that's not so bad Dr bright started
to say before o5-1 cut him off with
turns out the present was filled with
highly pressurized Napalm next time we
saw that team well let's just say the
Joker saved us the standard cremation
costs for employee fatalities oh Dr
bright replied yeah that's pretty bad
actually 05-1 told him that the solution
was exceedingly simple to defeat a
dangerous prankster you need to send a
dangerous prankster after them Dr bright
would be the perfect candidate to track
down and take down the Joker in the name
of the SCP Foundation but of course Jack
had one advantage that the Joker didn't
Jack was pretty much impossible to kill
however it wouldn't stop this demented
clown from hurting him really really bad
it was clear that the Joker somehow had
a mole inside the foundation which is
why for maximum security 05-1 decided to
keep this little Mission purely between
himself Dr bright and the foundation spy
that tipped them off to the Joker's
current whereabouts a lair he'd
constructed in an abandoned amusement
park in Gotham City Dr bright felt
tempted to comment that maybe this was a
little too obvious but decided to hold
his tongue because he didn't feel like
getting chewed out by o5-1 again today
he would be flown out to Gotham City in
a classified Foundation helicopter so
that he could enter with as little
Fanfare as possible from there he would
need to track down and incapacitate or
kill the Joker himself it wouldn't be an
easy task but at least it would distract
him from causing Mischief of his own at
the SCP Foundation in the meantime Dr
Wright soon found that they really
weren't kidding about Gotham City the
place was a dump it was like the very
worst parts of New York City and Chicago
had a dirty Gothic baby Full Of Monsters
And flamboyant super villains a hotbed
of malice poverty and unchecked crime
the kind of place where you could
probably get shot while leaving the
theater with your wife and your young
son even if you were some kind of
billionaire philanthropist there was no
surprise to Dr bright that a place like
this would produce a maniac like the
Joker he'd be eager to leave once the
grease painted freak Was Defeated rather
than risking any flashy Foundation
vehicle that might draw too much
attention to himself Dr bright simply
took a cab to the edge of the abandoned
amusement park it was a dark dismal
Place surrounded by a thick Mist that
really contributed to a general mood of
foreboding Dr bright could see figures
moving in the Mist so he lifted up his
para Foundation binoculars which would
easily cleave through the mist and get
to the truth of the situation Beyond and
the situation was definitely less than
ideal it was a hive of clownish activity
on the other side weirdly buff henchmen
and clown makeup carried large boxes
presumably filled with weapons or stolen
anomalous items while other muscular
mutant clowns carrying assault rifles
guarded them just beyond them there was
a huge fun house shaped like a giant
Clown's head given the Joker's General
lack of subtlety Dr Wright assumed
correctly might add that this would be
where the clown Prince of Crime would
choose to hang his hat that's where Dr
bright would sneak in club him into
unconsciousness with a foundation issued
defense baton and then calling back up
to take this bothersome Jester away it
was a perfect plan Dr bright infiltrated
the amusement park and began to sneak
through thankfully for him he'd learn
perfect stealth from years of discreetly
putting buckets full of water on top of
the doors of some of the SCP
foundation's most distinguished
operatives this made it an absolute Cake
Walk for him to slip in between the
offish freaks that the Joker had hired
straight from the greedy anomalous
ringmaster Hermann Fuller as bright Drew
closer and closer to the fun house where
the Joker was most certainly lurking he
wondered why this had even been
considered such a challenge by members
of the foundation's most well-trained
mobile task forces unless he thought
with an internal chuckle this whole
thing was some kind of ridiculous
elaborate trap though Dr bright didn't
get to finish that thought because
before that thought was stun a muscular
arm brought a blackjack down on the back
of Bright's head knocking him
unconscious when Dr bright awoke his ego
more bruised than his head thankfully he
was tied up at the bottom of a throne as
extravagant as it was strange atop this
Throne sat the Joker himself eating from
a plate of Little Caesar's crazy bread
though to a man as demented as the Joker
crazy bread was just considered normal
bread bride shifted on the ground
slightly and saw a familiar yet strange
face behind him wielding the Blackjack
that had laid him down not too long ago
it was a classic Person of Interest the
man with the upside down face also known
as Manny who'd been head recruiter at
the circus of the disquieting and
Hermann Fuller's right-hand man with an
upside down face Manny was an utterly
ruthless figure not above intimidation
violence and kidnapping to achieve the
goals of his employers it only made
sense he'd work for the Joker it gave
him a chance to continue doing what he
did best Jack's thoughts were
interrupted by a cackle from the man of
the hour
well
he gloated so delighted to finally be
making your acquaintance the ones that
they've been sending so far been so damn
boring it's why I've been sending them
back extra crispy
Dr bright struggled against his bindings
to no avail how do you know my name you
gaudy freak jackassed this got another
laugh out of the Joker Who Rose up from
his throne and began dismounting holding
an ornate walking cane with a tiny Gold
version of his own face on it for a
handle this guy really had a knack for
presentation I know a lot about you jack
especially not to lay a hand on that
pretty necklace of yours The Joker said
but in the
but I didn't know the great Shania Twain
that don't impress me much no Jack what
I find so interesting about you is the
fact that you seem to be the only one
working for those killjoys at the SCP
Foundation who has a sense of humor The
Joker was standing right in front of him
now Jack was at eye level with his fancy
black brogues if only he could get out
of his bindings Jack would complete the
obnoxious Clown's look by giving him a
big red nose but instead The Joker
looked at Manny and waved the upside
down faced henchmen away as Manny left
the room the Joker produced a long knife
from his coat Jack certainly didn't like
the look of that until the Joker leaned
over cut through Jack's bindings and
helped him to his feet even brushing the
dust off his lab coat I didn't bring you
here to die Jack oh that'd be a waste of
of it I just have somebody to come shoot
you and bury your medallion in concrete
The Joker said patting Jack on the back
no no no
offer you a job on the ground floor of
my new growing Enterprise I'm looking
for a team player someone with
experience and most importantly someone
who knows how to take a joke
Dr Bryant was confused this wasn't how
he expected this to go at all what
exactly is this Enterprise Dr bright
asked oh that's simple my good man The
Joker said I'm going to seal up all the
anomalies I can and then use them to
make this world a little more
interesting all those other groups I've
worked with including yours are too
focus on consolidating power even the
so-called chaos Insurgency really just
wants order their order me I just want
to be the life of the party I don't need
to be the host and with enough anomalies
I can tear reality a new one and make
everyone see the world how I see it the
ultimate prank the guy to end all gags
and in this new world Jack nobody will
tell you what you're not allowed to do
you'll finally be free just like yours
truly Jack thought about it for a moment
it was an undeniably exciting idea
finally working at a job that valued him
for his unique attributes being part of
something that let him be himself rather
than constantly scolding him for doing
what they perceive to be wrong who gave
them the right to decide after all Dr
bright could see the Joker's mouth
stretching into a wide grin as he
considered it could he really betray
everything and everyone to make the
world a more comfortable place for
himself Well Jack The Joker asked
what'll it be Jack's side and punched
the Joker in his grinning face the clown
staggered back Furious he yelled so
that's how it's gonna be huh okay Jack
guess you're just another Sad Sack Dr
Ryan stepped forward to take another
swing but the Joker grabbed at the false
flower on this lapel the flower squirted
a thin stream of highly concentrated
acid at Dr bright but the anomalous
Foundation researcher thought quickly he
grabbed and lifted up his indestructible
Medallion using it as a mini Shield to
block the ass it burns his hand a little
but most of the potentially devastating
damage was deflected as Wright continued
running towards the Joker the clown
pressed a button on top of his Cane
causing the device to turn into a sword
as the Joker swung for him Jack pulled
out his foundation issue defensive baton
they clashed weapons with impressive
speed and ferocity but the Joker
undeniably had a kind of vicious Killer
Instinct that Dr bright didn't Jack
killed to live the Joker killed for
sheer fun of it basic right you can't
beat me the Joker yelled and the joke
okay baby
but gloating was a mistake it gave Jack
a window well the Joker was midway
through one of his demented laughs and
their respective weapons were locked
into a mutual Clash Dr bright punched
the Joker in the throat with his spare
hand it broke the Clown's laugh off into
a choking sputter as he stumbled
backwards seizing his opportunity Jack
kicked the Joker in the chest and
knocked him to the ground clattering his
Cane sword from his hand no fair the
joker sputtered out Dr ride reached into
his coat to grab the emergency handgun
he brought with him but it was too late
the Joker laying on his back had already
pulled his own gun on Dr bright and was
aiming right at him the Joker didn't
hesitate he pulled the trigger bang as
in the word bang on a little flag popped
out of the wind of the Joker's pistol Dr
bright was bemused as the Jokers just
started laughing again this whole thing
really was nothing more than a big gag
to this guy wasn't it sorry Jack The
Joker said regaining his voice I
couldn't resist then the Joker or
squeeze the trigger again causing the
little flag to fire out with the speed
and force of a crossbow bolt thankfully
Dr bright was able to dodge causing the
flag to stick into his shoulder rather
than his intended target the heart but
Jack had had enough the exhausted
researcher pulled out his gun and aimed
it at the Joker's head he was bringing
this clown back to site-19 cold The
Joker still laughed even at this he
stuck out his tongue in a childish
gesture of spite I hate clowns Dr bright
said pulling back the hammer and curling
his finger around the trigger he was
about to fire when a black clad hand
closed around his wrist right turned
baffled to see Batman holding his wrist
sorry kid Batman said but I didn't get
into this game to let anyone get shot
not even him Wright was too confused to
reply The Joker gave a performative sigh
oh you always know how to ruin the fun
The Joker groaned before Dr Bryant could
formulate a reply Batman punched him in
the face knocking him out cold for the
second time today when Dr bright came to
both Batman and the Joker were gone to
God knows where Dr Bright's side rubbing
his aching head he really should have
taken the Joker's steal shouldn't he now
go check out scp-001 when daybreaks Dr
bright and scp-682 vs Dr bright for more
of the Wacky Adventures of Dr Jack
Bright